breaking news weil wir haben bernd
peters hier im studio aus der bild
unterhaltungs redaktion hallo willkommen
du hast
mögliche namen möglicher teilnehmerinnen
des dschungelcamps mitgebracht für uns
ja wir haben drei frauen die alle
voraussicht nach einziehen werden
das ist einmal die tina ruland die
kinozuschauer noch kennen werden aus den
manta manta filme neben til schweiger
dann haben wir claudia effenberg die vor
fünf jahren bei promi wasser den zweiten
platz gemacht hatte sich dort offenbar
empfohlen hat und wir haben lieder die
auch von den youtube juli schon die
zumindest träsch zuschauern sehr wohl
bekannt ist weil sie gerade das
sommerhaus der stars aufmischt ist mir
bekannt und damit ich mich als justin
zuschauer spannende kombinieren fall
oder also kombination aus diesen drei
frauen kommen wir noch ein paar mehr
dazu kann man da schon ein bischen
absehen wie diese drei frauen die wir
kennen sagen wir mal das dschungelcamp
bestimmen färben könnt ja wir haben also
rollen in der gruppen dünner
die erfüllen sollen oder die sie dann im
endeffekt erfüllen wir haben damit eine
mit liefer natürlich jemand der da kopf
und zünde reinbringen kann und durchaus
keinem streit aus dem weg geht das ist
in solchen formaten natürlich wertvoll
und dann haben wir jemanden mit tina
ruland die auch in so einem format neu
ist das ist auch immer spannend die hat
eine gewisse fallhöhe weil man sie dann
nicht erwartet und die claudia effenberg
könnt ihr natürlich so eine mutter des
camps werden oder mutter des schlosses
in diesem fall ja das könnte man sich
von ihr erwarten ganz kurz nach schloss
hast du angesprochen es findet
tatsächlich dieses jahr im schlaf stadt
nicht immer genau es wird etwas kälter
in diesem jahr corona bedingt ziehen die
werden die prominenten nicht nach
australien geflogen sondern in den
walliser wald dort steht ein schickes
schloss was rtl anmietet und dort werden
die prämisse diesem jahr einziehen also
kein dschungel im klassischen sinne
sondern ein weiter okay da sind wir
gespannt drauf ganz herzlichen dank für
diese exklusiven namen und wir sind
gespannt wie sich das der cast noch
entwickeln wird bernd peters ganz
herzlichen dank der nachrichten und
break linie es nur weil bild schau dir
das nächste video an und vergiss nicht
zu abonnieren